foreign
isn't just any new show it's your new
show where we get to investigate on
world events and where we get sa and
we've been doing this for quite a while
now because this isn't just any edition
of FYI it's our 200th episode
[Music]
foreign
we've got all of our current team here
with us including our newest recruit
Jiraiya hi guys and we've come together
to look back at 2022 and what a year
it's been I'd like to start right at the
beginning because things started to be a
bit more positive yeah back in January
life really seems to be getting back to
normal yeah especially with all the
restrictions out the window it felt like
kovid was finally behind us not for
everyone though because we started off
the year with an FYI investigation on
kids with long covid who struggle to
have their symptoms recognized months
after falling ill yeah but the good news
with that is that special on cover
clinics were set up I think they really
help at the long covered Clinic they
make me kind of feel like this is a
thing I'm dealing with it's not
something in my head and how to get over
it to help me with it and in January
vaccines were made available to people
our age but as life continued to get
back to normal for many of us in
February the world was about to change
again
President Putin of Russia has Unleashed
War in our European continent he's
attacked a friendly country without any
provocation and without any credible
excuse
Putin sent his forces across the
Ukrainian border and began an unprovoked
attack on the country bombing military
Targets in key cities including the
capital Kiev where I am now we have
several Air Raid Sirens per day and
people have to spend some part of the
day hiding in the underground shelters I
was staying in the bomb shelter for
eight days and that was really crazy
Russian forces have stepped up their
bombardment of towns and cities with
some places like the besieged city of
mariopol suffering awful damage now
around 3 million refugees have managed
to flee the country and most of them
have been warmly welcomed into
neighboring countries I'm here at the
Polish Center in lewisham in London this
is one of the drop-off points that has
been set up across the country to help
Ukrainian refugees
Ukraine needs help people may be
starving they've been walking
country to Country every day it's really
hectic here there are so many people and
so many donations we have been packing
all the stuff that people have been
donating and putting it in trucks that
are going to Poland
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
why isn't the UK doing more the UK has
progressively been doing more and more
and I it's not a competition but the UK
began by being the first European
country to to give military assistance
we're the biggest donor of humanitarian
Aid to the region and we will continue
to do as much as we possibly can and I
think we'll do that because we know that
that's what the British people want do
you feel bad that the UK hasn't taken in
more refugees but we are taking many
many more now as they as people decide
to come on to to the UK and that's right
I mean we've got an amazing record as a
country for taking people in and we
understand the importance of it
foreign
for myself what war looks like away from
the front line
children sometimes on their own
traveling across a continent to seek
safety
from February onwards millions of people
have made this journey
seen them arriving here frightened
and worried about what will happen to
the loved ones they've left behind
[Music]
near the railway station we met 17 year
old Elia who'd been traveling for 20
hours with her eight-year-old niece
Arena and a friend with a one-year-old
our ninth floor was destroyed and that
was the moment when I realized that I
gotta go and I just couldn't leave my
parents alone but I had no other choice
so what was it like having to leave your
parents behind
it's kind of hard for me even to think
of it because I have my I have tears in
my eyes because I don't know it was like
the most terrifying experience that I
ever had
so Scarlett you were actually in Poland
seeing the Ukrainian refugees cross the
border what was that like for you well
it was so upsetting seeing you know
young people in that situation I can't
even imagine myself in that position
then when you're actually there seeing
it happen firsthand and the effects that
war has on people it's so eye-opening
and it's so upsetting seeing them in
that position and guys it wasn't long
before the cover pandemic and the war in
Ukraine starts to have serious
repercussions for everyone yeah the cost
of food electricity and gas shut up
because the war and pandemic meant many
of our everyday essentials were in short
supply and all that led to some serious
political drama
it all started in June when prime
minister Boris Johnson was forced to
resign because he had broken their very
rules he had introduced to keep us safe
during the covert pandemic it's clearly
now the will of the Parliamentary
conservative party that there should be
a new leader of that party and therefore
a new prime minister
hey Braden so you made it to Downing
Street then what have you found out
about our new prime minister hey Maya
it's do you write her name is Liz truss
and she used to be in charge of
international Affairs but now she's in
charge of the country and she's moved
into the government HQ the home of the
government number 10 Downing Street
which is right there and she has some
urgent things to take care of right yes
so she's got two main issues that she
has to deal with number one being the
rising cost of things like food and
energy and the other one being the war
in Ukraine I have therefore spoken to
his majesty the king to notify him that
I am resigning as leader of the
conservative party Liz truss queer after
just 45 days because her ideas on how to
help us with the rising costs of
everyday essentials actually made some
things even more expensive and her party
lost trust in her Boris Johnson dashed
back from a holiday hoping to get a
second chance at being prime minister
but then changed his mind it was Rishi
sunak who got the support of his party
he is Britain's first Hindu prime
minister and a very successful
businessman the face of who runs our
country may have changed a lot but the
problems they need to deal with have not
changed
a war in Ukraine affecting millions of
people a shortage of fuel in everyday
needs which are leading to Rising costs
for British families
it was certain year of goodbyes wasn't
it not just in politics the world's most
successful tennis players retired Serena
Williams and Roger Federer and don't
forget Daniel Craig played his last ever
James Bond but let's not forget the
saddest goodbye that hit the world hard
I forced my France to comma today
because we're literally Living Through
History to me the queen was a very
important and special person in my life
because she was the queen when I was
born
[Music]
the new king and the royal family
followed in procession from Buckingham
Palace Thomas was in the crowd too as it
traveled along the mall
the coffin was draped in the Royal
Standard flag placed on top was the
crown worn by the queen at her
coronation in 1953.
seeing the procession was an honor to be
here and watch it it was really special
to see a moment in history right now
because it was so busy I ended up here
in Hyde Park watching on these screens
how does it feel being able to be here
today really special Builders we get to
see the last moments that we can see of
the queen I feel like the time right now
is when it actually feels real when
you're seeing the whole royal family
marching and the gunshots being fired
and it feels like time has stopped
thank you
[Music]
three chairs for his majesty the king
[Applause]
Queen Elizabeth was a life well lived
a promise with Destiny kept
and she is mourned most deeply in her
party
that promise of lifelong service I renew
to all today
while King Charles was one of the
original environmental campaigners and
he's been warning us about climate
change for decades in November we did a
survey of 2007 to 14 year olds which
uncovered that 50 of children are
frightened of climate change and only 10
believe that the government is doing
enough to combat it so did these results
surprise you guys I think also the
droughts in summer that was a real
eye-opener because it showed us what the
world could be like in 10 20 years yeah
it was such a hot and dry summer but it
wasn't all doom and gloom as a very
hopeful 63 of us said that it's not too
late to save the planet
foreign
one of the OMG moments of 2022 had to be
England's first win in the women's Euros
nice one
and disappointment at the World Cup for
the men's England team here's that Miss
penalty OMG moment but we are all proud
of Wales in England there were some
superb football an OMG moment for me was
waking up to this as we got closer to
the end of the year much of the country
was covered in snow and ice great fun
but also dangerous we've all been
reminded to never hang out on or near
frozen water
[Music]
one thing that we've all noticed in 200
episodes of FYI is no matter how tough
this world can get we all make sure our
voices are heard on this program we
finish with some of your stories that
made headlines right here on FYI
throughout 2022
I traveled to Brazil to meet Victoria
fighting for the world of professional
ballet to be more inclusive I think kids
even with arms wouldn't be able to do as
much as you can do so what made you want
to get into dancing especially having no
arms okinormous
what didn't make me give up was the
people who were always by my side who
supported me in all my decisions
and I headed to Jordan to meet
bannerella bed the child Refugee
campaigning for better conditions for
all those fleeing War
I've never been to refugee camp before
no I haven't and to be honest with you
I'm not really sure what to expect okay
this place opened 10 years ago and it
was just a hundred of tents in the
desert and it was just meant to be
temporary but now it's a home to over 80
000 people and more than half of them
are children
[Music]
and can you please tell me what is the
best thing about living in a camp and
what is the worst thing
the best thing there is nothing
and the worst thing
that we are living here
2022 saw more violence between
Palestinians and Israelis as both sides
continued to fight over land I went to
Israel to meet two young people from
both sides of the conflict hoping their
unique friendship can Inspire others to
seek peace how are you doing how are you
doing it's been so long since I've seen
you last time so happy to see you again
and across the UK you reported on your
stories
[Music]
I would like to apologize if he can't
understand me
I got a disability
coaches
and did comedy maybe help you overcome a
tough time at school yeah so I'm fine
with my speed as soon as I start to talk
to someone my speech which put people
off and they would avoid me so he is
telling them a joke would break the ice
and they would start to get enormous as
Great Ormond Street Hospital celebrated
its 170th anniversary our very own
Thomas had a story he wanted to share
with us thanks to this place I'm able to
run and be as active as I am I grew up
with a rare knee condition which limited
my movement it's meant that over the
past 10 years I've had 10 procedures at
Great Ormond Street this is my favorite
nurse Danny and then this is the man who
chopped my leg off you were one of the
most resilient and probably one of the
smartest children that I've had the
pleasure to look after and the fact that
you came to a lot of these decisions
yourself you're really one of the
bravest kids that I know and I'm really
grateful to have been able to look after
you
if you want your port for FYI in 2023
head to our webpage for more details or
even better get your school to set up an
FYI News Club all the details are there
Merry Christmas and a Happy New Year
from FYI
[Music]